لكن زعيم روسيا لم يحمل جديدا في
خطابه بينما يستمر الزيلانسكي في
بعدم طرد السوريين من بلده ويقول
نحن ابناء ثقافة تدرك جيدا معنى
شخصا في قصف استهدف مدرسة في
بلدة بيلوهروبيك. المحاصرون
لبحث منع وقوع حرب غير مقصودة مع
روسيا. الجيش الاوكراني يستهدف
الالغام. ماكرون لا يمكن بناء
السلام في اوكرانيا عبر اذلال
روسيا وعدم احترامها. وزير
الدفاع البريطاني بن والاس.
للدفاع عن اوكرانيا بتسريع توريد
الاسلحة الى اوكرانيا وتيسير
تقديم المساعدة العسكرية الى
كييف. بوتين يأمر بنقل القوات
للغاية حسب قوله. الاحداث
والتطورات. مع احتفال روسيا بيوم
ليرد مستشار وزير الموارد
المائية عن ذياب ان تدفقات النهر
وينتقل الفيروس من انسان لاخر
باللمس. الفيروس تحول الى ازمة
الاستوائية والبيئة التي يكثر
فيها تربية المواشي والحيوانات
المصابين به تصل الى اربعين
بالمائة الحمى النزفية تعود الى
احضان وايدي القتلة. انتظر
العالم خطاب بوتين في يوم النصر
مفتوح على مصراعيه وسنواصل
استقبال السوريين ولن نرميهم في
بلادهم متى ارادوا. اما نحن فلن
نطردهم من بلادنا ابدا. بابنا
النصر. الامين العام لحزب الله
في لبنان حسن نصر الله اي خطأ
توتر يتصاعد بين اوكرانيا
والمانيا خلال الاحتفال في يوم
قوله. فهل تكون روسيا قادرة على
فعل ذلك حقا? وكيف سترد دول
ستؤثر سلبا على وضع كوكب الارض
ولذلك سنضطر الى تحقيق فوز على
يتعين علينا منع حدوث ذلك لان
تبعات ضربات نووية متبادلة بيننا
اسرائيلي باتجاه لبنان لن نتردد
في مواجهته. الرئيس التركي يتعهد
بمصنع ازوفستال يناشدون لاخلاء
الجرحى ويرفضون الاستسلام. حكومة
اوكرانيا تخسر مائة وسبعين مليون
دولار يوميا بسبب اغلاق الموانئ.
الروسية في منطقة خركيف. امريكا
تضغط على تايوان لشراء اسلحة
امريكية الصنع لمواجهة الصين.
بسبب تسريبات حول تقديم واشنطن
وخمسمائة مليون دولار وتعتبر
روسيا هي السوق الابرز للسلاح
ان هناك صفقات اسلحة كبيرة وغير
مسبوقة. فكيف ستكون ردة فعل
تحذيراته وهذه المرة حذر العالم
اجمع خطر روسيا. اما بايدن فيريد
لافروف زيارته الرسمية للجزائر
التي تاتي في الذكرى الستين
مصدر في صحيفة موسكو تايمز. كرم
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي اشهر كلب في
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يوقع
على قانون الاعارة والتأجير
المهاجرين انصار وبامكان
اللاجئين السوريين العودة الى
وهنا نشطاء عراقيون مقطعا مصورا
يظهر شابا يركض وسط نهر دجلة دون
معلومات لكييف في قتل قادة روس.
بايدن يستدعي القادة العسكريين
من ارضنا. الجيش الاوكراني يقول
انه استعاد قرى من القوات
زالميسكي مواطنون يناضلون من اجل
الحرية لاطفالهم وسنطرد المحتلين
قاعدة للقوات الروسية في خركيف.
حاكم لوجانسك يعلن فقدان ستين
على الهواء. وتتعرض بيربوك
وحكومتها للانتقادات بسبب تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحة الثقيلة
مؤخرا. الحليف القديم. استهل
لقوات الجيش الاحمر السوفيتي.
وهنا ياتي الرد سريعا برشق وزيرة
هذا العدو اقوى اقتصاديا وعسكريا
باساليب القتال التقليدية حسب
محافظة ذي قار جنوب العراق.
الفيروس ينتشر في المناطق
الغرب وامريكا على على الجزائر
بروسيا. قوة روسيا. قال ديمترو
بوتين يجسد الشخصية الفاشية
والناتو لم ولن يخطط لغزو روسيا.
النصر مناورات عسكرية بين قوات
اللادفية والبولندية لحلف الناتو
البلاد يدعى باترون لدوره في
مواجهة الحرب الروسية للكشف عن
الروسية من سوريا الى لتسريع
العملية العسكرية في دومبس بحسب
في بغداد تصل الى اربعمائة متر
مكعب في الثانية. وهي كمية كبيرة
ان تغمره المياه ما يعكس مدى
الجفاف غير المسبوق الذي ضرب احد
اهم الروافد المائية في البلاد.
فهل وصل نهر دجلة الى النهاية?
قوله. رد السريع. هاجم محتجون
معارضون لغزو روسيا لاوكرانيا
الخارجية الالمانية انالينا
بيربوك بالبيض اثناء كلمة لها
اندريف عندما توجه على رأس وفد
روسي لوضع الزهور على نصب تذكاري
الصادرات الزراعية الاوكرانية
فان عشرات البلدان في اجزاء
وانتشار الوباء. فيروس قديم
متجدد لا علاج له. نسبة وفاة
مختلفة من العالم على شفا نقص
الغذاء وبمرور الوقت يمكن ان
الغرب كان يستعد للهجوم على
روسيا وان قرار العملية العسكرية
الناتو اقوى حلف دفاعي في العالم
على ذلك? العراق بين نضوب دجلة
ليزيد الغرب قلقا من غموضه هذا.
كارثة عالمية. الرئيس الاوكراني
وبائية خطيرة في العراق. بسبب
عدم وجود لقاح يحد من انتشاره.
العراق وتودي بحياة ثمانية اشخاص
وتصيب اربعين اخرين معظمهم في
نقدر موقف الجزائر المتزن بشأن
الازمة الاوكرانية. ويصل حجم
روجوزين مدير وكالة الفضاء
الروسية ان موسكو تحتاج الى
لتأسيس العلاقات الدبلوماسية بين
البلدين بوضع اكليل من الزهور في
يصبح الوضع رهيبا بصراحة. لذلك
يجب على العالم ايقاف روسيا بحسب
السفير الروسي لدى بولندا سيرجي
اندريف حيث قاموا بالقاء الطلاء
قوات الجيش الروسي وهذه الضربة
ليست لاوكرانيا فقط. فبدون
كان ضروري وصائبا لان روسيا كانت
تواجه تهديدا غير مقبول اطلاقا
بالنسبة للجزائر وبعد هذه
الزيارة الروسية تقول التقارير
التبادلات التجارية بين موسكو
والجزائر الى اربعة مليارات
ثلاثين دقيقة فقط لتدمير دول
الناتو اذا نشبت حرب نووية لكن
على الحدود قائلا ان روسيا حذرت
الاعداء ولكن الغرب لم يرد
مقام الشهيد بالعاصمة ليظهر
العلاقة الودية بين البلد لافروف
الماضيين على خلفية انتشار فيروس
كورونا. بوتين شارك في الفوج
الاحمر عليه خلال تواجده في
العاصمة وارسو. وسخرت حشود من
في تصريحات متلفزة تم حظر الحياة
العادية المرتبطة بالبحر من قبل
الانصات الى روسيا لم يوضح بوتين
عن مخططاته خلال الفترة الحالية
بوتين الذي حمل صورة والده ظل
كعادته حاملا حقيبته النووية.
احتفالاته وجاهز للاطلاق من جهاز
في حقيبته اينما كان وفي اي وقت.
الخالد حاملا صورة والده الذي
شارك في الحرب الوطنية العظمى.
وهناك يرسل رسالة للغرب ان
السلاح النووي لا يفارقه حتى في
بوتين فهو لا يظهر خططه للعلن
كالعادة. وقال الرئيس الروسي ان
رسائل بوتين للغرب. بخطاب بلا
مفاجأة يكتنفه الغموض. هكذا ظهر
في اوكرانيا. واشار الى ان حلف
شمال الاطلسي كان يثير تهديدات
بيوم النصر شارك في الحدث بعد ان
توقف عن ذلك خلال العامين
الرئيس التركي يصدم العالم ويقول
كلمته الاخيرة تجاه السوريين.
الازمة. فهل بدأ ماكرون بالتملك
بوتين الغامض. في احتفال بلاده
تقلق الشعب العراقي. وحزب الله
يهدد اسرائيل بهجوم غير متوقع.
بيننا وبين حلف الناتو ايلون
ماسك يخطط لطرد الف موظف في
الرئيس الاوكراني يحذر من كارثة
عالمية محتملة. هجوم على السفير
للغرب ما الذي سيفعله في خطواته
المستقبلية وفي الطرف الاخر
تويتر. بينما روسيا تحذر ايلون
ماسك من التدخل والعبث معها.
يكرم كلبا ويضع له الوسام
العسكري. نهر دجلة يعلن عن فاجعة
الروسي في الجزائر. وموسكو تقول
ثلاثون دقيقة ستكون هي الحاسمة
الروسي في بولندا بالطلاء
الاحمر. ولكن ياتي الرد سريع على
وزيرة المانيا بالبيض. وبريطانيا
تستمر في استفزاز بوتين. فهل يرد
ضخ اسلحة اكثر لاوكرانيا والازمة
تتعقد اكثر فاكثر.
وبخطواته الثابتة حاملا حقيبته
النووية ظل بوتين غامضا لم يكشف
وامريكا تضغط على تايوان وماكرون
اذا لم نحترم الروس فلن تنتهي
الروس على هذا الاستهزاء? ظهور
مفاجئ يقلق الغرب لوزير الخارجية
بخطواته المتسارعة في مسيرة
الخلود حاملا صورة والده